i'm looking at her um at the poster
and she sticks her tongue into a taser
yeah
here here he is
zach
[Music]
oh and rachel
hello hi buddy hi i haven't seen you in
so long congratulations on all your [ __ ]
like where do i sit here yeah
and you can use you can make that mic
come over
or maybe they switch spots so that she
could be in front of the mic
okay
give her the headset
thank you hi zach hey how's it going i
was just talking about the last time i
saw you and you could tell me because
i'll edit it out if you don't want me to
talk about it but you you were at my
son's apartment yes yes i didn't know
you i knew nothing about you
and within 10 minutes you have uh uh
crazy glued your mouth to some guy's
chest
and that's not it and then is it okay
that i say this yeah okay and then and
then we you said you wanted or signaled
that you needed a coffee we walk down
the street like that
we went to starbucks
yes and you ordered a coffee yeah that
was an awesome time no i want to ask you
is that a beard and a mustache or is
that what's remaining of the friend's
chest that you bonded
hilarious that's a good question
oh man that's a shitty answer
um
no it's a do you mind i have a video is
it okay to show the video or i don't are
you okay with it you can show it yeah
yeah okay and i can show it
alex and rachel you are the first female
cast member that uh
they uh they had a girl in the
television show
but they got she got severely hurt
thank god really thank god so now
there's an opening for you yeah and so
what happened she was doing a stunt with
uh dave england is do you do you know
the exact style i have no clue i think
she was doing a stunt and she got
injured and i don't think they could use
the footage and i think they said that i
think knoxville said from that moment on
they weren't going to have women does
knoxville really he runs that show right
uh jackass
i mean he's he's our our dear leader
right but also jeff germain the director
i mean yeah yeah because we have to get
a no
we this is going live right now but that
we have to hold it they said till
show are you coming out on the fourth is
that yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah so we got it we just got a
call from the studio oh nice to hold it
to the fourth we're live
wasn't there guys that got hurt too you
just like yeah there i mean obviously
the guys um get hurt have you gotten
hurt i did get hurt what happened but
nothing like nothing that that would
cause uh them to withhold any of the
clips um i i got i mean when you got
when you got cast you were male 1
i was and then i then i became more
female as as the uh the sh the movie
went on no um i got you know i the
things that i did like the in the
trailer you see i get bit by a scorpion
that was probably the most painful well
they just showed a poster of you and
your tongue is on a taser is that yeah
that one that also was uh unpleasant
isn't that dangerous it is dangerous yes
but i like but i like it the scorpion or
you like pain i mean i think i like
exploring well women we can we can
handle pain and in a lot of ways that
men can't ever understand but i also
think that
there is a line where women getting hurt
still can be funny
so i like to explore that line yeah
women getting hurt can be funny you can
say that yes if i say that if you say
that you can end up in jail
what's the worst injury you ever had
zach um i snapped my leg in half before
uh i was just trying to skateboard it's
on video though
it it's just like just snapped
completely in half and i have a video of
that too oh yeah yeah if you type in
like zach like the zackass like leg
break
zach asks i don't want to see it these
are like the worst oh i can still barely
watch it it's so gnarly do you hear it
uh kind of and you wanna hear it there's
like a really uh funny part where i like
you'll you'll see it okay you go you
watch it you should point out what the
funny part is oh yeah
so he's on a ramp he falls over and oh
okay that's that's the normal one that
was me
watch
right here right there you see the leg
[Laughter]
oh my
god you got nice butt crack though zach
looking at his ass his legs
it's over and over in slow motion
[Laughter]
and you thought
i want to do a movie where this can
happen to me all the time yeah
[Music]